(bounce music)
- I'm Katey.
I made it, I said it,
I ate it, ya heard me?
(bounce music)
I am from New Orleans, Louisiana,
and I'm a bounce artist,
aka The Legendary Katey Red, iconic.
(bounce music)
I was known to be the first
transgender/homosexual
rapper, bounce artist.
(bounce music)
♪ Bounce bounce, do that,
work work, do that ♪
- [Narrator] That, is Miss Katey Red.
A legendary bounce artist who's
been doing it for over 20 years.
But before we get to her
story, what exactly is bounce?
- People may call it "twerking,"
the correct name for it is "bouncing."
It's shake-your-ass music,
that's what bounce music is, it's
shake-your-ass music.
(dance music)
- [Narrator] The origin of
bounce music can be traced back
to the mid '80s, to a DJ duo from Queens,
known as The Showboys.
They took the theme from Dragnet
and sampled it into this:
("Drag Rap" by The Showboys)
Eventually, it made its way to New Orleans
where the beat got sped up, looped,
and by the early '90s,
bounce was a mainstay
in New Orleans music.
Soon enough, bounce went from
a hyperlocal New Orleans sound
to influencing some of
mainstream's biggest artists,
like Drake and Beyoncé.
("Formation" by Beyoncé)
- [Katey] I don't know what
it is about that sound,
but whatever that sound be,
it have you moving to your feet, baby.
(dance music)
My fist concert, I was scared.
I was scared, I was so nervous.
As soon as I got up there, and I was like
"How y'all doin'?"
and they was screaming out loud,
"We love you! We love your music!"
And I'm like, (sigh of relief),
that was like, what a big relief.
Let me hear y'all over here,
"Come on, Katey baby, come on!"
- [Crowd] Come on, Katey baby, come on!
(bounce music)
- [Narrator] It takes a certain amount of
brashness and bravado to
make it as a bounce artist.
Let alone as an openly
gay or transgender one.
But Katey is not one to
shy away from anything.
(bounce music)
- Thank y'all, thank
y'all so much for coming.
I wish I got more time with y'all.
Me opening doors for a
lot of bounce artists
and all the gay artists,
I think about that a lot.
The bounce scene is more
acceptant, but at first it wasn't.
I was bold and brave, but at
the same time I was scared,
but I still had to do me.
A lot of gay guys would
come up here and say,
"Katey, you are the reason
I told my mom I was gay,"
because I was like, I
live in the city of music,
I make people be who they are,
and who they really wanna be.
You only get one life, and
nobody can run your life but you.